the ukrainian member of parliament
alessia vasilenko is part of a
delegation to the european parliament
and is currently in strasbourg for us
thank you very much for being on the
program today can you just explain what
you are doing in strasbourg
essentially
nine ukrainian members of parliament all
women are part of the international task
force to ram up support ukraine uh both
from eu countries and council of europe
countries so last week it was the
session of the european parliament and
we were working uh the delegations of
the eu parliamentarians to see how we
can
move more on more sanctions more robust
sanctions against russia especially with
certain countries who
took half measures
and also how we can do more to expedite
ukraine's membership in the eu
this week is going to be about the
council of europe expelling russia from
every single body of the council of
europe the committee of ministers last
week failed to make such a decision so
it's now up to the parliamentary
assembly of the council of europe
tuesday and monday will be the decisive
days and we hope that the resolution
with the final resolution will read that
russia will not just be invited to leave
or of its own accord and hence be uh
able to come back whenever it sees fit
but that the resolution will read that
russia is actually expelled and then it
will be up to the council of europe
countries to uh make the decision of
when uh they are happy to welcome russia
back and invite it back
you mentioned there that some countries
have only taken half measures on
sanctions who are you talking about
well it's the obvious ones uh germany
france uh
the the major countries they're not
doing
nearly as as much as they could be doing
the same goes it goes for the purchase
of russian oil and gas okay germany made
the decision yesterday to stop with the
purchases of oil and coal uh but gas
still remains a big one every penny that
goes into the russian economy goes to
finance the russian army which
essentially is committing a genocide of
the ukrainian people by massacring
civilians every single day uh every
single day i wake up to the news that
more and more civilians were killed
there are more civilian losses in
ukraine than military losses that says
something about the type of warfare they
are waging it's a terrorist state waging
a terrorist war against an independent
nation and they must be stopped with all
means and money and economic sanctions
are
very strongly towards them
um it's absolutely horrific what you say
and i just want to talk a bit about the
position you find yourself in and we
might better show a picture of you i
believe
um you've uh taken up
a gun yourself and you say that you're
prepared
to use it
you've got three children including a
nine-month-old
just just talk me through you're in
strasbourg at the moment are you
planning on returning to ukraine at your
children in ukraine what's your own
situation
uh so my my own situation is complicated
you know how you you put the
on your social media profile it's
complicated this is my situation right
now uh
i'm uh very blessed to be in a much
better position than many people living
in besieged towns such as well navajo
which has been destroyed yesterday since
yesterday it's a town in ukraine which
had one hundred and thousand one hundred
thousand people and now it's no longer
considered livable it's no longer a town
uh
yesterday it was the last day that city
was existing as a city so i guess i'm
lucky that that at least i'm living
breathing i'm in safety i'm in a country
right now where there is no war where
missiles are not flying my kids are in
safety uh i in fact have a couple of
hours with them uh
just now just as we speak so uh i'm
extremely blessed that i have the
opportunity to at least see them for for
at least a while but uh once this
diplomatic mission to strasbourg is over
that's it i go back i go back to ukraine
that's that's a set uh
said given but uh where do i go back to
ukraine i don't know because uh
my um
my trip to to uh
to to this uh to strasbourg and later on
it will also include the uk uh so on
next week i will also be in the uk also
trying to speak to government officials
and parliamentary parliamentarians uh
regarding uh regarding more sanctions
and regarding more support for ukraine
but really after that on dating so much
i go back to ukraine the question is
where where is that going to be uh
because every time uh i look at the news
more and more cities are getting bombed
as well in western ukraine so it's very
very indefinite i hope to be able to go
back to kiev to
my own apartment at some point um
i mean i as a normal person i miss it
greatly and
i would love to just be home and have
somewhere to call home
yeah i can completely understand that
and thank you for you know sharing the
experience that you're feeling like so
many people in ukraine i just want to be
able to go home and you mentioned there
that you are hoping to speak to the uk
parliament and see if there's more that
they can do
and spoke to michael gove and um also
the labour leader kier stammer on the
show today
asking if there were any points at which
the uk should escalate its response to
things like providing more weapons or
providing a no-fly zone it felt that
they were quite reluctant to commit to
anything like that what do you make of
the uk government's position
well today ukraine relies most on the uk
and on the us to be honest these are the
two strategic partners that have always
been around through all of the eight
years of war that russia has been
waiting against ukraine uh today the uk
has uh uh
well not only the opportunity but also
in
my view the responsibility to become the
leader of the anti-putin coalition which
is forming in eastern europe uh
yesterday uh in the speeches we heard
from uh
from
russian tv presenters which are
essentially the rupers the the
microphones of the kremlin uh the
message was very very clear that after
ukraine russia is not about to stop and
that they are going to continue their
invasion across the eastern uh block of
countries to to get back that big
russian empire they all dream about
essentially that is a declaration of
of war on uh european states and on nato
member states before it's too late i
feel that the santi putin coalition
formed of uh baltic states of poland of
uh georgia possibly although georgia has
been very very quiet these days
surprisingly um
of the uk again of the nordic states
this anti-putin coalition could really
be uh the the thing and the mechanism
the vehicle that can stop putin uh
before it gets too late and before the
extent of the damage and the extent of
losses of people's lives grows more than
that of the world war two
um it's it's as you say the the loss of
life is so devastating what are people
telling you um from ukraine you must be
speaking to people and friends family
members who are still
there every single day uh i to be honest
i i feel guilty for even getting like
the the four or five hours of sleep uh
that i've been getting through these uh
uh a little bit more than two weeks
through these 18 days uh because every
time every hour something is happening
uh there's either missiles or shellings
or evacuation buses being shot uh
tonight uh really the attacks have
extended uh to to the west of ukraine
actually that happened already since
last night uh as well um
so now they bombed this uh
peace and security center that was
located uh just outside of leave just 28
kilometers away from poland people in
poland were sending messages saying that
they heard tremors in their homes as
everything in the night shook
so this is how far they are pushing now
they're really the russians are really
pushing on the borders and i think it's
gonna be uh very little time before they
start attacking poland
that's really concerning and perspective
and thank you so much for taking the
time to
talk to us this morning we appreciate it
thank you thank you